et frontières pour moi ça commence déjà
entre l'homme et la femme c'est là où
est la frontière c'est pour ça que je
voulais que les femmes viennent pour
parler un peu de la vie parce que elles
en savent
et puis il ya une chose qui m'horripile
je dis ça parce que les frontières entre
l'homme et la femme
c'est que une guerre comme celle qui ce
qui se passe partout dans mon lien n'a
pas qu'une y en a partout des foyers de
violence est toujours traduite par des
viols et ça c'est une chose qui me
choque profondément qu'on s'attaque à
une femme c'est comme si on s'attaque à
sa mère à sa soeur à sa fille le type
qui viole une jeune fille et qui
habillés en militaires avec son fusil ou
avec ses copains et qui fait ça qu'est
ce qu'il explique comment il s'explique
quand il rentre chez lui et à qui
regarde sa fille qui joue et qui lui
caresse les cheveux qui la prend sur ses
genoux et comment ils se jugent comment
ils essaient d'expliquer ce qu'il vient
de faire à une autre femme ou un autre
jeune fille qui n'est pas de sa race
soi-disant ou qui n'est pas de sa
culture ou qui vit différemment de lui
ça je trouve ça particulièrement
scandaleux et c'est un des grands
problèmes quand l'homme a changé
d'attitude par rapport à la femme par
rapport à son regard afin de n'aura plus
besoin de se voiler parce que le regard
de l'homme sera sera clair si elle a
besoin de se voiler c'est parce qu'on
pense que le regard de l'homme est
corrompue par rapport à la femme
c'est ce que je pense que je voulais
dire par rapport à la mi-janvier
[Musique]